all right joining us now former New
Jersey Governor Chris Christie out with
a brand new memoir about his time in New
Jersey politics in the 2016 campaign let
me finish Trump the Kushner's panin New
Jersey and the power of in-your-face
politics available on amazon.com
wherever books are sold
governor good to see it how are you
trami I'm sorry um before I get to all
the political stuff you know do we
really need 27 FBI agents tactical gear
guns drawn pre-dawn raid 17 vehicles
including armored vehicles to arrest a
guy that has no weapons in his house a
guy that is charged with lying to
Congress no and listen you know that
I've defended Muller I'm over the course
of time over the last you know 18 months
or so defend this man I can't I can't
defend this no defend Andrew Weissman
with his record and Angie near a and
every appointment is a democratic I
can't defend Andrew Weiss when I
wouldn't defend Andrew Weisman but what
I'm telling you is that this is a
problem for Bob Muller why couldn't find
publican why profile how does he hire
Clinton Foundation attorneys listen and
part of that by the way by the way part
of that is almost every one of those
people came from inside the Justice
Department part of that problem is that
there was no turnover when Jeff Sessions
was Attorney General to get new people
into those positions how's the answer
Weissman still the head of the fraud
section of DOJ for the entire time that
jeff sessions is the Attorney General
for Merrill executives to jail for a
year overturn Fifth Circuit right nine
zero loss in the Supreme Court tens of
thousands of Enron accounting employees
lost their workforce and and and so to
me why was he still in the Justice
Department to begin with how does the
Attorney General the United States
permit him to be in the Justice
Department and on the raid this was
Muller's choice to put Weissman and
Jeanne Ray on this team
I understand all Democratic donors John
I understand I'm not defending that and
I'm not defending the raid the raid is
wrong there is no reason if he did not
have weapons in that house there is no
reason to go with tactical units with
flak jackets on with automatic weapons
and all the rest there's no reason for
it except to intimidate that's the only
reason to do it and that's and that is
an absolute inappropriate
use of prosecutorial Authority you
talked about that the president thought
if general Flynn's fired the whole
Russian thing is over obviously not the
case you see and you say one of the
reasons you don't believe it is because
as every campaign is there's chaos
nobody has time to say oh let me meet
with Putin no listen I was there for a
good part of the campaign as you know
and then moved over to the transition
but as I said this was a campaign and
you know about this campaign and I say
this in a miring way having lost to them
well I've been having them won the
presidency this was not a traditional
organized campaign and they were not
going to do some Tom Clancy routine with
luke collusion when they were still
trying to figure out how to hire field
operatives in pennsylvania we know that
was the situation there that campaign
won because of the power and the ideas
and the articulation of Donald Trump and
that's what you hear from me in this
book Sean is that would thought to eat
he talked to you about being vice
president it was down to me or Mike
Pence absolutely and and you mentioned
me in the book thanks a lot well listen
you're part of the story of that I love
the invention listen you tell us what
why do you tell stories like the story
about McGreevy why do you talk why
because to me it's like all right that's
sort of private between you and I think
that's right well first of all was it
because we're a whole bunch of people
that we were all talking at the same
time you didn't have to put in a book no
but I this and I think it's an important
thing to show this president's humanity
and it show his sense of humor you know
I think he's drawn by the mainstream
media as a cartoon character and what I
show in this book is this is a guy who's
a great father and loves his children
and I tell those stories in the book
about his genuine concern is he got
closer to the presidency about what
effect this was gonna have on his kids
and on this kids being able to be
successful in the business and him
always being there for them and now he
wouldn't be able to because of this job
I talked about the great sense of humor
that he has and the jokes that he played
on me I talked about the fact that he's
the first person who sat across from me
and said Chris you need to get lap-band
surgery well years before I decided to
do it while I'm trying to show by
telling these stories is the humanity of
Donald Trump because people draw him
like a cartoon character and he is and
he's much more complicated than that did
hit your prosecute did Hillary Clinton
violate the Espionage Act with that
server yes did Hillary Clinton obstruct
justice with the
subpoenaed emails deleted those emails
while the subpoena was pending then yes
okay do we not have all Brennan
clapper you know all these people that I
mentioned they not lie to Congress and
got caught how come they don't get the
raids in this case so why don't you why
don't you take an hour one night and
have jeff sessions on here and asking
those questions I think he I don't know
what he was doing I always liked Jeff
session look that's my point this is it
was it turned into a disaster who you
pick as Attorney General matters it's
one of the things I talk about in the
book the president has been victimized
by some bad choices that were
recommended to him and by a process that
didn't work well for him are and they're
worried as a former prosecutor and
governor that we have a dual justice
system we have all these other people
that lied either under oath or to
Congress nothing happens to them for
example Hillary funnels money hard money
can't pay money through a law firm so
it's legal expense to hire an OP
Research Group right hire foreign
national which is wrong who uses Russian
lies that they spread to the American
people before the election and then they
use it to bludgeon the president ever
since but then they go to a FISA Court
we now learn that everybody in the FBI
and DOJ were warned by Bruce or that
Christopher Steele hates the president
and the candidate Trump that Hillary
paid for it and that it's unverified how
do you not verify and it turns out a lot
of its lies hookers ritz-carlton boss
how do they get away with all of that
and Muller pays no attention to it first
of all we don't know whether he has or
he hasn't yet bull well I don't see it
at all you know we listen but we don't
know yet so let's wait for the end of
the report and but but here's the other
thing let's say he isn't paying
attention to it where was the Attorney
General of the United States hires a
team of Democrats which shown an a pit
bull Andrew Weissman and Clinton's own
former turning and by the way I'm not
defending those hirings but what I'm
saying to you is if in fact that's
what's going on and Muller is
independent of what they're doing at the
Justice Department while you're smaller
put that team together here's what I
here's what I believe is that right from
the beginning
the Justice Department under Donald
Trump was not running the way it should
have been run and because of that okay I
got a when there's man last class you
can't divide the two one other thing the
most important thing you said tonight
and the reason to answer the question
you began by asking me is of course I'm
concerned about this because if we don't
have a fair justice system we don't
democracy is over our republic said if
this is allowed that's and that's my
last question
FISA Court there was a conspiracy to
commit fraud they never verified the
lies that they put in the document they
minimized Hilary's involvement shouldn't
all of those people now themselves pay
that price every one of those people who
participated in that should be subject
only rot Rosenstein to exactly a same
scrutiny to exactly the same scrutiny
that bob miller has given to all of a
sudden it's not it's not happening and
it's Shawn and that's why I hope that
the new Attorney General that the
president will do this because guess
what this is the job of the Attorney
General of the United States and I was
US Attorney for seven years and you know
what we had we had one of the best
Attorney General's this country has ever
had in John Ashcroft he never turns away
from anything and in a time when our
country was at grave danger
post 9/11 John Ashcroft empowered his US
attorneys to stop terrorism and we
didn't I got it one attack afterwards
Sean that's an effective Attorney
General Chris Christie's book let me
finish by the way you always finish all
right thanks for being with us thank you